so everybody can um ask questions can i
mute him
herself for himself and ask questions
without any into the q a session so
we thank the simon staff for for helping
with this
um now the first week of today i will be
broadcasting from the coast of the
mediterranean this is emmanuel millman
from the technion
and the title of this lecture is sharp
isolated inequalities for fine quail
mass
integrals please great thank you very
much boss i think you can hear me yes
uh so uh it's a pleasure to to to speak
at this conference and thank you for the
organizers for the invitation
uh everything i'm going to talk about is
joint work with amir udayev also from
the technion
uh and although i'm not quite sure
it's it fits perfectly into the theme of
concentration or measure phenomenon
uh uh you know i'll i'll do what i can
and maybe towards the end i'll mention
something which is maybe more in line
with the interest of of of the workshop
okay so let me start
but now it doesn't move very strange
okay so let me start so uh
just recall our setup we have a convex
body capital k
in rn so by convex body i mean a convex
compact set with non-empty interior
uh and the classical fact dating back to
the
uh 19th century is that if i take
my body my convex body k and set wise
add to it
a euclidean ball of radius t so t times
b to n the euclidean ball
uh and i take the volume so anytime
essentially any time you see absolute
values in this talk
uh i i mean uh volume in the
um or the beg measure and the uh
underlying
a fine hull spanned by the set
see if i can see myself yes uh then this
volume
turns out to be a polynomial of degree n
in the variable t and the coefficients
here
uh modulus sum some normalization the
coefficients are called the
the k coefficient here is called the kth
quermus integral
of capital k so there's capital k
there's a little k i'm sorry for the
notation but that's
the way it is uh sometimes these are
called intrinsic volumes
okay so this is not a very explicit way
to define them
uh there are various other additional
ways one can use a formula and
differential geometry by
integrating various curvatures along the
boundary of k
uh for us in this talk we'll be more
interested in an
integral geometric uh formula for these
chromos integrals
uh given by kubota's formula uh and this
is it so
up to some some normalization uh
basically what you do is the following
to compute them
you integrate over g and k where g
and k uh for for the rest of the talk is
the grasmanian
of all k dimensional linear subspaces of
rn okay so this thing is a homogeneous
space
the orthogonal group acts on it
transitively so it carries a har
measure and we denote the associated har
probability measure by
sigma so basically this integral just
means that you take
around a uniform randomly sampled
a k dimensional linear subspace f
you orthogonally project k onto f
and you take the k dimensional label
measure the k dimensional volume
and then you just take the expectation
okay so just the average
projection onto a k dimensional subspace
uh
so for instance let's see a couple of
examples so the n
minus 1 chromosome integral it's
actually easy to see what it is from
this formula
it's basically the linear coefficient in
t so it's basically the first derivative
and t so the first derivative of volume
under
addition uh is just uh surface area
modulus some scaling
and that's exactly what this guy is okay
it's the surface area
uh on the other extreme if you test the
first
the w1 the the one chromos integral
then it's easier to see what happens in
this formula so basically you project
over all possible one-dimensional
directions
and you calculate the uh one-dimensional
length of the projection so this is
basically the width of the body
in the direction so what you get after
you know some
normalization is basically the average
width the mean width of the
of the body okay so these quermis
integrals or intrinsic volumes are you
know
very important in corner store
parameters of uh
which you can associate to any convex
body
and the classical fact is the following
uh if you fix
k from 1 to n minus one so the other
cases zero and
n are not very interesting the classical
uh
fact which i think is due to alexandrov
but maybe
possibly quite possibly even before is
the following sharp
isoparametric inequality for these
square must integrals
uh the k chromos integral for any convex
body k
is lower bounded by whatever happens to
a euclidean ball having the same volume
as capital k
which i always denote from here on as b
sub k
so the b sub k is just a euclidean ball
having the same volume as k
so this is a sharp isoparametric
inequality with equality
if and only if k is a euclidean ball
itself
okay uh so for instance uh when k is
equal to n minus 1
this is a sharp lower bound on the
surface area so this is a really
a genuine isoparametric inequality for
the surface area
for convex sets and for k equals one uh
this is a sharp lower bound on the
mean width of the set and this is called
the orissan's inequality
okay so this is a completely classical
fact and this is the starting point of
our work
because back in the 80s erwin lutwak
defined the following
variant on the these classical chromos
integrals he defined the kth
affine quermas integral as exactly the
same thing now we denote these by
phi sub k okay it's exactly the same
thing as before
one takes the l minus n norm in this
integral
okay and why are they called athline
because as it turns out this was shown
by eric greenberg
these guys are indeed invariant under
volume preserving affine transformations
of the convex body
i'll just say for short affine invariant
okay so these turns out to be uh
affining variant and as such
uh they are the central pillars of
affine convex geometry which is
uh the study of convex body bodies
modulo
uh the group of affine transformations
okay
uh these are completely uh fundamental
parameters
and also in the 80s yes can you say a
few words
why can you say before it's about the
proof
it does not look completely obvious well
well that's that's
yeah okay so i think the origins go to
an observation of first bergen zucconi
which is a dual observation
which is an identity that they
discovered for ellipsoids but the proof
is really um you know a combination of
different geometry with a little bit of
lee algebra
so i cannot really give you intuition
besides the fact that
there's only one power which makes a
defining variant and that's minus n
okay you have to look at the volume
element and do the computation yeah
but so can't you just use the
can't you just write the df uh and check
how it changes in the fine
transformation
because it's you know you can express in
terms of support function your house
support function changes and you have
the dual vector that i can
do just that you know the usual agree
that it's a computation
it's a computation it's not very easy
actually it's not
it's not elementary but you're working
you're welcome to do it
in any way that you can um
okay so so anyway these are affine
invariant and the natural conjecture
posed by irwin
is that they should satisfy the same
sharp lower bound the same isoparametric
inequality
as before but now since things are a
finite variant
with equality if and only if k now is an
ellipsoid not a euclidean ball
and of course by jensen's inequality the
l minus n norm
is smaller than the l one one so this
isn't
this is uh uh this is harder should be
harder
uh and in fact uh this is the exactly
the right power to make things a finding
variance so this will be a strengthening
uh an affine invariant strengthening of
the general of the classical case
okay
so that's the conjecture now uh let me
note that the rank one cases
by rank one i mean the rank of the
corresponding grasmanian so the case is
k equals one and co dimension equals one
k equals n minus one
the rank one cases of uh ludwig's
conjecture are completely classical
so i'll i'll show you in a second before
before let me just recall
uh some standard notation we denote by h
k
of y the support function of the convex
body k
in the direction of y this is a one
homogeneous function
okay just the width in given direction y
and also the polar body
is just the unit ball of the uh
of the dual norm associated to case so
if you want this is just the
one level set of the support function
okay so now let's check the case cake
was one
of lutwak's conjecture i claim this is
exactly the blush quesantello inequality
uh why is that well if you project onto
a one-dimensional direction spanned by
theta
what you get as we said before is just
the width in the direction of theta plus
the width in the direction of
the antipodal direction right now by
using a very
elementary and standard uh formula of
calculating the volume
of a body by using a polar integration
what you have to do is you have to
uh if you want to calculate the volume
you have to raise
uh the the radius to the power of
capital n
first square minus integral which is the
integral of this to the power of minus n
is up to some some normalization it's
exactly the volume
of the polar body to k minus k because
we're adding
k in the antipodal direction okay so
that's an
elementary computation so if k is origin
symmetric
then k minus k is just twice k so you
know the factor of two just pops out
outside
just changes normalization a bit and you
see that lutox conjecture is exactly
equivalent
to the statement that the volume of the
polar body to k
is now upper bounded because we didn't
raise it to a negative power so now
it's upper bounded by the volume of the
polar body
of the euclidean ball having the same
volume as k okay that's
the conjecture and if you re-uh
re-insert the dependence on the volume
inside
you get that the volume product of k and
its polar
is upper bounded by whatever happens to
the euclidean ball
uh and that's exactly the celebrated
blaschke santelo inequality which is
you know just cornerstone of convex
geometry
for general k uh one has to be a bit
careful because the blaschke santalan
equality
now now it's important with respect to
which point you take the polar body
so if you take the polar body with
respect the so-called santa low point
which is the point uh for which this
volume of the
of of the polar is minimal then uh
this is called the blaschke sunderland
equality and you can check that this is
slightly stronger than ludwig's
conjecture but
both are both of course true okay so k
was one is blush question i should
mention historically that the
quality case and the blush cast antelone
equality for regular enough convex
bodies were was established already by
blush and santalo
for general uh origin symmetric bodies
this was done by saint rimon
and for general bodies this is due to
petty
okay so this is the case cake was one uh
the other
codom and the other rank one case is the
case k equals n minus one
and this is exactly uh what is called
petty's projection inequality
let's see why so in the in this case we
have to project to a co-dimension one
hyperplane perpendicular to theta
and it turns out that the volume of this
guy if you extend it as a one
homogeneous function
is a convex function so so it's the
support function of some
this is i think this is due to minkowski
actually so this is the support function
of uh some convex body which is called
the polar
uh which is called sorry the projection
body of k pi of k
and this so so if you look at the polar
body which is pi
which is denoted by pi star of k then it
turns out that
the n minus one fine coordinate integral
is up to some normalization
exactly equal to the volume of this
polar projection body
so this means that ludwig's conjecture
is exactly equivalent to
the falling sharp upper bound on the
polar projection body of k
and this is exactly what petty proved
okay this is petty's projection
inequality again
completely classical inequality in
convexity
so these cases are well known and i
should mention that of course
after the original proofs of these
inequalities uh various
people have contributed and extended
these results
so this is just a partial list uh campy
gronkie lutwak mayor pejor reisner
yang and jang and i apologize if i
missed anyone which i
surely did okay so these are the
classical cases
um some related results uh regarding
bluetooth conjecture so it
has been shown by powers and pivovarov
that if you're not quite going after the
sharp result then using methods from
asymptotic geometric analysis
you can get the result up to some
constant strictly smaller than one
to the power of k so this is this was
known
um another related result concerns the
dual theory so it turns out that in the
brewminkowski theory
uh everything in the primal theory has a
dual version where you replace
uh but in the dual version one replaces
the operation of projection by the
operation of intersection
and in this case turns out that you need
to replace the power of minus
n to the power of plus and to get an
affine invariant
quantity this was also verified by eric
greenberg
and then you get an affine quantity
again which is called the dual affine
chromos integral
phi tilde but for for the dual theory
usually things are easier and indeed
it was shown by boozman and strauss and
reproved by greenberg
that you do have the do sharp
isoparametric inequality now the lower
bound becomes an upper bound
uh with equality if and only if k is an
ellipsoid at least if
k is larger than one uh and i should
mention that uh
richard gardner so they show this result
for convict sets
richard gardner extended this results
for arbitrary bounded borel sets
and then the quality cases are much more
delicate okay
but this is in the dual theory okay
i should also mention going back to the
primal
affine chromos integrals uh we're
interested in lower bounds
but uh of course upper bounds are also
very interesting
and here even the classical case uh at
least
for the at the reverse inequality to
blush constant
uh this is the celebrated mother's
conjecture which you know people
i could devote a whole talk just on this
conjecture so let me not do that but you
know it's wide open
in dimension 4 and higher just very
recently it was resolved in dimension
3 for origin symmetric sets uh
remarkably i should mention that the
other rank 1 case the case k equals n
minus 1
is actually known the sharp upper bound
is known this is due to
zhang who showed that the upper bound is
attained whenever k
is a simplex so that's quite remarkable
i think actually
for origin symmetric convex sets the
sharp upper bound is not known
of course it's conjectured to be a
parallelo so
still an affine image of a cube but i
think that's not known
but anyway in this talk we're interested
in lower bounds
and basically the uh the higher rank
cases
beyond the classical cases have remained
wide open since the 80s
i i'm not even familiar with a single
partial result
emmanuel can i ask you a question yes
you know in the in the upper bounds is
there any
moral reason why the case k equals n
minus one is easier than the case k
equals one
that's the million dollar question right
i i know
all right well if you manage to do
muller no no but but what is the what is
the
moral difference between the different
case i i
it's this is why i say zhang resolved is
quite remarkable
i i want to give you a good answer
except an empirical one the proof is in
the pudding i don't know
how does the proof work well maybe this
is not a good discussion for now but uh
all right i'll let you go on with your
talk thanks
uh okay so this was uh what was known
and finally arrived to our results which
as i said our joint
everything is joined with the mili
yudayof so we fix the convex body k
we fix little k uh and our first theorem
is indeed resolving bluetooth x
conjecture
uh in all possible ranges of parameters
with the equality cases equality if and
only if
k is an ellipsoid so that resolves uh
everyone's conjecture
theorem two is a strengthening of
theorem one and
immediately implies three and one uh
basically we show
that anytime one applies steiner
symmetrization
in a direction u then the affine chromos
integral can only
go down can never go up so what is tiny
symmetrization so here's a very nice
graphic i downloaded from the internet
uh basically so here in this graphic uh
don't use you you use theta so what you
do
uh so you you look at theta perp this
could i mention one hyperplane okay you
look at
every at a one dimensional fiber over
each point
uh so this intersects k in a by
convexity by in a one dimensional
interval
and you just translate this interval
until it's symmetric with respect to
its base point on theta per okay and you
do this for each point so of course by
fubini's theorem you preserve the volume
and moreover it's very simple to see uh
that you preserve convexity
so you still get a convex body and it's
a classical
result dating to the end of the 19th
century beginning with the 20th century
that for any
any convex body in fact any compact set
you can find a sequence of directions ui
so that if you apply
standard symmetrization uh consecutively
in the direction of u1 you tunes and so
on then
uh your your convex set will converge in
any any possible
topology that you like uh to a euclidean
ball having the same volume so volume is
not
lost in this procedure so therefore a
theorem two immediately implies three m
one
okay so this is a first strengthening of
theorem one
uh second strengthening is given by
theorem three
which states that not only are
ellipsoids are the only global
minimizers
unique global minimizers of 5k but
they're actually the only
local minimizers again with respect to
any topology that you like
they're all equivalent okay um
these are our results for this talk i
should mention
uh let me go back to the classical cases
the rank one cases
uh so certainly this inequality the
inequality here has been previously
known for sure however the equality
cases are actually quite delicate
uh so in the case k equals one uh the
blaschke santalo case
the fact that standard symmetrization
decreases the well increases the volume
product
in the origin symmetric case this is due
to mayor pejor
and i think in the general case this is
due to meijer and reisner
um so this was known uh oh oh by the way
when i say equality case
maybe i should explain when i say
equality i mean what hap what
so so let's assume that you know that
for any direction you
the steiner symmetrization has the same
affine chromos integral
as the original body so you cannot find
a single direction with when it's
decreased
then it must be an ellipsoid this is
what i mean by the equality case
so this follows from uh and the blaschke
santelo case uh this was known
but however in the petty case it seems
to us that this is actually new
this observation so even there i think
we
we managed to do something new uh and
what about theorem three the local
minimality
uh this was just recently established
for blasquez antelope by
mayor and reisner in fact for the volume
of the
polar body around the centaur point but
again
for petty's inequality this again
appears to be new
okay and and the fact that k equals n
minus one is harder is actually
in line to our own investigation so in
the quality cases
we treat all the cases in one fell swoop
no problem
however the case k equals n minus one
requires
additional work so we need an additional
section in the paper to handle that case
so
this case does seem uh harder
so well knowing that the ellipsoids are
the only local minimizers
yeah is it possible to set up some kind
of gradient flow on the space of bodies
um right so we tried various we tried
many many things uh standard
symmetrization is of course very natural
and there's a
we used at the end a continuous version
of steiner symmetrization
uh but uh i don't i i'm not familiar
with an interpretation of this
as a gradient flow of course if you
in fact i'm not sure i know a lot of
interpreter
you know i'm not sure i know proofs of
the classical results and convexity by
doing what you suggest as a grading flow
that would be very very interesting
of course there are various uh well okay
there are various geometric flows like
mean curvature flow and they're distant
cousins
which can produce some of these
classical results in convexity
at some point we even you know dared to
try to do it for this problem
uh but but we don't know how to do it
certainly
uh there are some flows which are a
finite variant
mostly with respect to uh affine surface
area so i think there are proofs maybe
by ben andrews and others of the affine
isoparametric inequality for convex sets
by using a certain
curvature flow which is affine invariant
but
nothing of the sort that you suggest
that'll be super
interesting also basically
okay so these are our results
um so let's try first attempt you know
let me go quickly because this doesn't
work but just to see what you can do
well you can say well come on i can
prove this problem let's just do the two
co-dimensional case
k equals n minus two and that's of
course the first idea you have is
let's do double integration because we
can what does it mean to select a random
n minus two dimensional subspace i can
first erect a random
one co-dimensional subspace call it e
and then
take a random one co-dimensional
subspace of e which we
we get f okay uh so let's try
to to to calculate this integral of
course you can apply patty's projection
inequality to the inner body but the
problem is this body lies in dimension n
minus one now so you cannot you you
would like to apply to calculate
this integral for q equals n but we can
only do it for n
minus 1 here if you want to apply
petty's projection inequality
uh and by entering this inequality you
can do any q which is smaller than n
minus one that's not a problem but you
cannot go above that would be false
so if you apply petty to the inner body
then you get something
only involving the volume of this inner
body which is this
and then you can apply petty again and
get something
involving the volume of the body and you
don't really need to keep track of the
constants because
along all the inequalities we had
equality for euclidean ball
so in other words what we are able to
show using this approach very simple
approach is
this inequality that's completely
trivial using petty
however we don't get the right power we
want to get the power of minus
n we get the power of minus n minus one
and you can do exactly the same thing
for general k dimensional subspace
we're going to get the wrong power we
want to get minus n we get minus k
plus one so we lost the defining
variance doesn't work
and in fact we had a dozen at least a
dozen additional approaches
all of which always uh hit this barrier
we can
be on this power in like a dozen
different approaches and at some point
we even thought that maybe that's really
the truth you cannot do better than that
does it imply the result of foreign
so of course i mean they their result is
up to a constant to the power of k we
get a constant of one
with the characterization of the
equality cases
oh you mean this no no no no yeah uh
does this yes yes we
we can do something like that but i mean
we
okay okay so what is
why is it so challenging okay let me try
to explain i don't know if i can but
uh you know we we've worked on this on
and off for several years
and just this year we we had a finally a
success
um so the right how how are the rank
one cases proved uh at least classically
so what you do is you associate your
convex body k an
auxiliary convex body this will be
either the polar body or the polar
projection body let me call this
auxiliary body
lk apolog apologies to the slicing
people
and it lives in euclidean space rn and
what does body do it encapsulates the
function we're really interested in
okay in a certain way it turns out that
uh in the classical cases you just have
to calculate the volume of this body to
get
what we're interested in the affine
chromos interval in those cases
and the point of the point is to show
that there's standard symmetrization
the volume of the this auxiliary body
can only increase
okay so the inequality gets reversed
that that's not a big deal
this is so so how is this body obtained
in both of these cases
it's obtained by identifying our
grasmanian
with real projective space rpn minus one
which is just you know just the sphere
with antipodal points identified
how do we do this of course in the
one-dimensional case we'll just
intersect the sphere with the
one-dimensional line
and the one co-dimensional case
intersect with the with the
with the perp with the perpendicular
direction so that's
this identification is trivial and then
we basically get a function which is
defined
an even function defined on the sphere
so you can extend it to the entire rn
just by
taking a one homogeneous extension and
if we take its level set we exactly get
these bodies either k-polar or the polar
projection body
and then it remains to see what happens
under standard symmetrization
um the problem with the higher rank
cases is that we no longer have this
identification
so it's not so so of course uh the
grasmanian in the hieron case
uh you can't embed it in r capital n
for a large enough end but you either
have to use
a very large n and then this embedding
is highly non-injective
or you can use a uh you know small
capital n
but then the embedding is non-linear so
you lose something and
really we tried both well at least the
first approach
and nothing seemed to work and in
particular it wasn't clear to us
in which space should should our
auxiliary body reside
because you cannot do it in our in in
the same dimension anymore
and at the end our our solution was that
first of all
to realize that first of all we don't we
do not know how to construct such a
universal body in fact
our auxiliary body will depend on the
direction you
in which we're performing the steiner
symmetrization
secondly this body will reside in a
vector bundle
over the lower dimensional gross mania
okay so you don't have to worry about
these fancy words
the construction will be very simple but
this kind of resolved in which space
should the auxiliary body reside as a
small price instead of taking the bag
measure
and showing you know this inequality as
before we're not going to use the label
measure and this vector bundle we're
going to use a slightly modified measure
mu sub u
okay and that's kind of a very high
level description of what we're going to
do
what does it mean a convex body in a in
a in a manifold
you mean geodesically converter is
convexity not imported anymore
yeah well we'll i didn't say this
auxiliary body will be convex
oh no it says convex body
that's just the case one and one is fun
right
okay okay so just in this case it was
convex we will see that
in our case it will be also convex in an
appropriate test
in a sense okay so let me without
further ado let me show you the
construction of this
auxiliary body which we call the
projection rolodex
hopefully this name will be suggested uh
so first of all some notation if i have
a
k minus 1 dimensional subspace e in a
point x and our n
let me denote i think this is a very
suggestive notation
uh this this projection onto e wedge x
and taking absolute values
so basically what we do is we want to
take the
k dimensional the beg measure of the
projection of k
onto the span of e and x generically
this will be a k
dimensional subspace okay but we want to
make this into one homogeneous function
so we also multiply by the length of the
projection of x
onto e perp okay so if x is
uh is or is is perpendicular to e then
you could you know this is just a
trivial one homogeneous extension okay
so in most cases
x x will be perpendicular to e
okay so having this notation let me
define what we call the
e projected polar body l sub
e k so this body lives in e perp
and it's basically the one level set of
this function
okay we take we make we only take
we we only consider x and e perp because
movement
of x and parallel to e doesn't change
this function at all so this function
has a trivial product structure we just
want to see the the non-trivial
you know throughout the trivial factors
so we don't only consider x and e-perp
so a little lemma which i'll leave to
you to check i don't know if i'll have
time actually i've seen running slow
this guy is always convex in e perp
okay so this uh answers something about
convexity
uh let's just check what happens uh when
e is the trivial subspace
zero okay then well this function is
you just basically project well you just
basically project
uh to to dimension one uh what is the
projection to dimension one as we said
before already it's the support function
in the direction of x plus the support
function direction of minus x
so this is exactly just as before the
polar body to k
minus k so this guy is trivially convex
okay but this is always true this guy's
always convex
here comes our definition which we call
the projection rolodex
so basically it's a collection of all
tuples
e is a k minus one dimensional subspace
of u perp
so this is going to depend on you and x
is just an element of
our e projected polar body so in this
sense this body is convex and
the reason we call it projection
relative you know i think i hope you
guys remember what was the rolodex
before the invention of the cell phone
it was this kind of you know table a
collection of these notes
so i'm you know so each of these notes
is basically this polar
body lek and they're kind of a lot
they're kind of arranged uh
and indexed by this lower dimensional
gross mania okay
i hope the name is suggested note that
this projection rolodex encodes this
function
okay why let's see so take a generic
k-dimensional subspace f
and intersect it with uperp okay and
call this guy e
generically this will be a k minus one
dimensional subspace right so
this is okay we still have one
additional direction to choose let's
call this direct the
the orthogonal direction uh given by by
theta so theta is an element in on of
the sphere
perpendicular to e okay
uh and what does it mean to be inside
l e k what does it mean so t theta is an
lek so this is just a one homogeneous
function so t pops
outside so this happens if and only if t
times
the volume of the projection of f
of k onto the span of e and theta which
is f
is at most one so this means that the
radius
in which we can go in the direction of
theta is one over
the volume that we're interested in so
this means that you can read off
this volume that you're interested in as
just the norm
in the direction of theta associated to
this lek body
so really the information that we're
interested in is contained here yes
it is a good idea to think about this
projection world decks as just
fairly projection bodies with respect to
various subspaces that's the way you
think about it so you know on each page
you have a projection body
of the of am i right you need to pay
your projection body
of the projection to the one-dimensional
up subspace
i mean white if you any so each slide
okay that's that's another way yes
okay so i will i'll just
heads up to the organizers i will aim
for the 55 minute mark
because i've been asked questions is
that okay or yeah
okay um
yeah so the second ingredient we need is
the blaschke petkanchi type formula
which uh you can find in the beautiful
monograph by schneider and
veil and from now what we've from now on
we fix the direction u
always be fixed and this uh blush kept
conscious type formula says that
if you're interested in integrating
a function f with respect to the harm
measure on g and k
so up to some normalization this is the
same as doing the following things so
first of all you can select
a k minus one dimensional subspace of u
perp
okay but then you still need to select
uh you know a
a a direction on the sphere respect to e
perp
but if you just do this randomly and you
calculate the integral you'll get the
wrong answer because there's a jacobian
factor here right
and it turns out that the right jacobian
factor is this guy in red you have to
you have to uh um amplify by the
cosine of the angle of your of your uh
of your theta k with respect to the
direction u raised to this power
and the intuition is well if you do this
just randomly without any weight
you'll be giving too much weight to
subspaces
uh which are uh close to the equator you
want to penalize them and you want to
give more weight
to subspaces which are are closer to the
north pole to you
okay that turns out to be the correct
answer
uh but as a corollary of this formula if
we define the measure mu
sub u to be just this is just the bag
measure on this vector bundle that i
mentioned just
you know you select e to be a random
subspace of u perp
you take the label measure on e perp and
you multiply by the jacobian
then it's immediate to see that it's
very simple calculation but i think i'm
out of time
it's a very simple calculation to check
that the mu measure
of this projection rolodex is up to some
normalization
exactly the integral that we're
interested in
okay i actually wrote down the proof
it's basically doing polar integration
after you pass to e-perp okay and
this jacobian factor exactly makes
things
so that the power that you get here is n
it's a very simple computation but i
think i'm running low on time so let me
skip this okay
but this is really the full proof uh and
this is being recorded
so you can you can check it out later
but uh it's a it's a very simple
computation based on this
blush kept kanchin formula okay
so with this in mind what is our goal
our goal is to show that uh and by the
way i didn't say but
i'm only going to show you an idea of
how to prove the
inequality i'm not going to talk about
the equality cases
at all uh you know the big breakthrough
for us was
showing that finally the the inequality
the sharp inequality here
and once you do this then you if you
have equality here you can start looking
at you know all the equality cases what
does it mean
it certainly requires more additional
work and some new ideas but
you know this is already uh something
that you can work hard and do
uh but you know the idea of showing the
inequality was the big big
big uh kind of breakthrough for us so
i'm only going to talk about the
inequality
so how do you show that standard
symmetrization can only decrease this
guy
well as i just showed to you it's the
same
as showing that the mu measure of our
projection
rolodex can only increase under standard
symmetrization
right because this guy is the same as
this modulus of normalizations
so this is going to be our goal and
notice and this is the was the key
the key thing for us that now everything
is aligned with you
right the direction of this time of
symmetrization the definition of the
projection rolodex
and the measure mu they all depend on
you okay
and in fact we're going to need to apply
one additional last alignment
so how how are we going to prove this
when you calculate the mu measure of
this projection rolodex
so you integrate with the spec 2 this is
just the you know the
you select your random subspace e and
you perp you take the labeg measure on e
perp
but remember that e is a sub
e is perpendicular to u e is a new perp
so this means that
u is an element of e perp so when we
integrate over e perp we just
fubini we first integrate in the
direction of u
and then we integrate over everything
else and this is quite this is the last
alignment that we need and this is quite
convenient because then you see that the
angle with u
is just given by s where s is the height
along the direction of u
okay so this this this guy the scalar
product just becomes
s and we see that we get s to the power
of k minus 1
outside and what we have left is we have
left
the volume of the we have left just the
volume of this body
indexed by by this level set
let me give this a name let's call this
body l
e u s of k so this is just the
section of our uh e projected polar body
which is parallel to u polar at height s
so the idea is to fix the height and
integrate just over that section
and we just have to calculate its labeg
measure now just its volume
okay uh and now
every so now it remains to show so the
whole idea was to pinpoint
where does the standard symmetrization
do so now it remains to show
the key inequality that for this body
steiner symmetry is once you fix the
height s standard symmetrization
can only increase its label measure
okay so basically what you see on this
slide
was the was the key idea
okay was to use was to pass to the
projection rolodex to this measure and
to make one final alignment
and then it remains to show why standard
symmetrization
increases the volume of this body
okay so we need a bit of convexity
um how am i doing on time okay
um so let me introduce some notation uh
let me denote
by a superscript y the one dimensional
section of
a in the direction of u over
the point y in u-perp so just a one
dimensional section
okay and let me use r sub u
to denote the reflection
about u perp okay so what we're going to
do
is we're going to introduce a very
simple continuous version of
steiner symmetrization so we have this
one-dimensional interval
k superscript y and we have its
reflected version
so let's just use a a convex combination
with weights which sum up to 1. so
weight 1 plus t over 2
and weight 1 minus 2 over 2. okay so of
course
at time t equal 1 we just get the
original body
at time -1 we get the reflected body
and at times zero we get exactly
sinusoidalization okay
in fact this makes sense for values of t
which are outside this interval minus
one one
but then these guys are one of these
guys is negative
and remember we're adding stats so
this guy actually is no longer it's so
so for instance volume
is no longer preserved when you're
outside this interval but this makes
sense
you can still do this and in fact this
is a very particular instance of what is
called a shadow
system so i don't want to get into that
but if there are some experts in
convexity
listening in uh this is a very
particular i think this is called
minkowski linear shadow system
but all of our results in this slide
apply to general shadow systems
so the key inequality the key where does
convexity come in
is in the following uh proposition uh
which states the following so you fix
your subspace e you
fix a height s
that's very important then the function
mapping y in uper and t t is our time
parameter
to this guy so you fix s
you fix the red but you allow yourself
to
move to to deform your body to make a
continuous standard symmetrization and
to move y
the claim is that this function is
jointly convex
okay that's the claim uh it's very
simple to see that it's even
because it's even so if you flip
simultaneously the sign
of y and t then it's very
easy to see that this function remains
the same because if you flip the sine of
t
basically what you're doing is you're
reflecting your body
okay so calculating the volume of the
reflected body
onto a subspace is the same as
calculating the volume of the original
body to the reflected
subspace right but reflection our u of
e doesn't do anything because u is
perpendicular to e
so reflection of e doesn't do anything
the only thing that happens is you
change the sign of s
when you reflect with respect to u but
changing the sine of s
is the same as keeping the sine of s and
changing the sine of y because it's just
the antipodal point
so you don't change the span so this
function is very
trivially even but the point is that it
is
convex okay and how are we going to use
this
we're going to use this because this
means if this function is jointly convex
and even
this means that it's level set which i
wrote here
its level set is a symmetric convex body
obviously
okay let's give this body a name l tilde
e u s
and again we're only interested in what
happens inside e perp because if you
change y by something parallel to
parallel to e
then this function remains constant so
we might as well intersect with e-perp
so we have this so assume that we we
show this this means that the level set
is a symmetric convex body
notice that the t section the section of
this convex body at high t
is just by definition the body
that we're interested in and now
it remains to use the classical fact
that if you have a centrally symmetric
convex body this axis
is the t-axis then the volume of the
central section
is always larger than the volume of any
other section
okay so this is written here this is
exactly what we want to show
this is exactly what's written here
because the central section
is exactly k u at time zero
and this section is k u at time one why
is this this is just the
obvious trivial argument that uh i'll
just remind to
to to the audience so basically by by
convexity
uh we know that the section the central
section
contains by convexity the one-half
one-half
inter convex interpolation of the
section at t
equals one and a t equals minus one but
due to
due to symmetry these sections are
exactly the same just with the minus
sign
okay but then if you apply bruminikovsky
inequality to
to to both sides of the inequality
you'll get what we wanted
okay so at the end of course there's
convexity and there's brumikovsky in the
background
but the whole point was to pinpoint
where it is
okay so once you have so i hope i
managed to convince
you that once you have this proposition
you are done
uh and in fact it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be easier to have some
functional version like the breast
complete
similar to how campyground can do that
like you don't um you can't like instead
of using
it to see what i'm no no okay this
argument is trivial i don't know what to
say
i mean just this part if you have a
simplified proof no no no no no no no no
yeah no but this is just telling that
the volume of the central section is
you know it's a monotone it's an even
function of t which is monotone
decreasing now i'm not saying it's not a
simple fact i'm saying
like if one could avoid the use of
auxiliary bodies
but yeah i don't know how to do that
okay okay so
this is the key proposition i'm not
going to show you a proof
let me just very quickly because i do
want to get to something else
uh at the i'm not i wasn't planning on
showing you a proof
uh but i'll just tell you the idea
we actually so this wasn't the hard part
okay
showing the convexity we actually more
or less knew about the convexity
the hard part was you know aligning
everything with you so you know if i
gave you this exercise show the
convexity
uh you know if you believe it's true
then you will work and you're short it's
not
but uh so we actually have several
alternative proofs of this fact because
each
version had its own advantage we needed
a certain version to prove
theorem three about the local minimality
but anyway the idea which is common to
all shadow systems
is that actually you can take you can
realize this volume of the projection of
kut
as the projection of a body k tilde
living in one dimension higher
okay so that's the rough idea and the
point is you have to fix
s because when you project this higher
dimensional body k tilde
you get an expression which is actually
it's when you fix
x it's an affine function of y and t but
it's a non-linear function of s with t
so this is why you really have to fix
the height s okay so i'm not going to
show you this proposition
because in my last five so so basically
this is kind of the sketch of the proof
that i wanted to show you
and everything else is you know you can
you can try to do by yourself but
basically you have the whole idea
uh i do want in my remaining five or six
minutes i want to say
uh something a bit uh very simple but
related
okay um so
you can do you know so so now let's go
back to our definition of the
square must integral we used of course
minus
n in this entire talk but you could use
the lp moment equalmas integral which we
denote by
this calligraphic q let's use the lp
moment here
and of course the case p equals zero is
interpreted in the limiting says as some
type of geometric average
so the case p equals one is the
classical case the classical
chromos integrals the case p equals
minus n
are the alpha chromosome integrals in
the case p equals minus one
these are also this case has also been
studied by hadwiger
and by erwin ludwig this is called for
obvious reasons
the harmonic chromos integrals because
you're kind of doing a harmonic
average so as an immediate correlation
of
our main result just by applying the
enzymes inequality if you manage to
prove lower bound from minus and you'll
be able to prove a lower bound for p for
any p
larger than minus n and the claim is
that you have the same
sharp iso-parametric inequality for
these p-th coordinate intervals
but now you lost a finite variance so
this have you have equality if and only
if k is a euclidean ball
uh i should mention that the case p
equals minus one was already proved by
erwin uh that's not u but
but going all the way down to minus n um
maybe that is new
and i should mention you know why do we
stop at minus n maybe you could go below
no the inequality below minus n is
simply false
even for ellipsoids that would be just
false because you'd get
you'd have to use jansen's inequality
going in the wrong direction
it would be a strict inequality and
you'd be dead in the water so so this so
really p equals minus n is the last uh
and the sharp
affine invariant exponent which you can
use
um the last thing i want to mention this
is my last slide
uh is a relation to luminous
loomis-sweden inequality which maybe is
more interesting to to this community
which i know there are
many computer scientists in the audience
with and loomis whitney is used
a lot um so what is the classical
loomis-whitney inequality
uh it stated for any compact set k
uh if you take the projection onto
the print the n minus one dimensional
principal
hyperplanes okay you take the product of
these volumes
then this is at least as large as the
volume of k to the power of n minus one
this this gives you the right units
and as loomis and whitney remark in
their paper for any reasonable set k
uh its its surface area is always going
to be at least
twice as large as a projection to any
hyper plane
right because surface area element just
decreases
and for any reasonable set you're going
to hit this hyperplane
at least twice from from either side of
k so this is true certainly for convex
sets for
many other sets uh so you might as well
take a geometric average
okay which means if you apply the result
which means that the surface area of k
is at least as large as twice times the
volume raised to this power
so this is a an isoparametric inequality
for k
but it's not sharp it's with the wrong
with the wrong uh constant here
but the but it is you know it already
gives you a subtle
inequality if you want and so on so this
is nice
uh and of course by reverse induction uh
you can also get this version
so instead of taking a one all principal
uh
one co-dimensional subspaces you can
take all principal
k dimensional subspaces okay project
onto them take the product and you'll
get this is larger than
the volume of k raised to this power and
in all of these inequalities you have
equality
exactly for a box whose axes are aligned
with your given orthonormal basis
so in fact the motivating question for
us for this entire work but of course we
went
in completely kind of the other
directions after that
uh is the question was can you improve
the lumis whitney inequality if you
average on the choice
over all possible orthogonal bases
because then it's no longer sharp
because there's no single box
you can claim that you get a sharp
inequality because now there's no
distinguished orthogonal
orthonormal basis so certainly this
inequality would still be true if you
average
but it will no longer be sharp so
question what is the sharp inequality
and what's the
what's the extremizer so we can
easily answer this question now in fact
we can do it before
as well so if you take a geometric
average over all possible orthonormal
basis basically you're averaging over
sln
here right so if you apply a random
element
of son to your to your k k-dimensional
subspace
you just get a random k-dimensional
subspace right uh so what is this
integral
this geometric average over all all or
thought orthonormal bases
is just the integral over g and k of
this expression
and we overcounted by uh by n by n
choose k
right because we had uh n choose k
elements here
basically what you get is exactly what
we call the zeroth
the l zero chromos integral k zero
and by the theorem that we have from the
previous slide
and in fact we could and this is indeed
what we did several years ago
we could we can just use ludwig's p
minus 1
result we don't need to use our full
result by incidence inequality
any power which is smaller than zero
would work so we can lower bound this by
whatever happens to the euclidean ball
having the same volume of k
and if you compute and see how this
affects the volume this is what you get
so we get
this inequality and this is a
sharp average luminous witty inequality
which now is sharp exactly for the
euclidian ball because this inequality
is sharp
exactly for the euclidean bulb so we
have equality if and only if k is the
euclidean ball
and now everything is sharp the extremal
case is the euclidean ball so
this means that this actually does imply
the sharp
isoparametric inequality for at least
for convex bodies
which is an improvement over the
corollary that lumis and whitney had
because they got an as appropriate
inequality with
with a non-sharp constant but now this
average version
does give to you the sharp constant
anyway so
this is kind of funny that was the
motivation for our work
we discovered that actually ludwig can
do p minus one which is more than enough
than what we need but then you know we
recalled
actually everyone has this conjecture
and we got stuck on the conjecture and
at the end we're very happy to to to be
able to resolve it
um anyway so this is all i wanted to say
thank you very much
thanks emmanuel for this great talk on
an elegant result and we have time for
one quick question just one maybe
so i have a quick question actually so
congratulations first of all in this
beautiful result
uh but um so i was wondering if your
argument was written basically
and simplified in the case k equal to
one it sounds like you would get campy
grunky paper is that correct
okay now what no no so
after okay so as i said we have
um okay
first of all uh actually uh
something which could have inspired us
or or maybe when we had to prove
theorem three we noticed that we can
give uh
an alternative proof of that key
proposition which i did not show you
uh by actually mimicking the proof i
would say
of uh of mayor pejor actually obliges
okay i would say was more influential
for us but no because
they have the same kind of thing because
when
they calculate the volume of the polar
body they freeze
the height s and they see what hap what
standard symmetrization does
so actually if anything this is similar
to that
however a very crucial difference is
exactly what i said
before which is that um the
we need to freeze the direction you so
we always have to work in a subspace
which is
perpendicular to you and this is
something which
is not apparent in any of the previous
results uh
or proofs not in black santa not in
petty
so the key really the key to proving
this was
to align everything with you and to
define
our projection rolex if you will but
that's because you use
minkowski in a subspace rather than just
complete functionality but anyway
but my question was actually so if you
write your proof simply for k equal to n
minus one
do you get uh uh a new proof
shadow system proof of petty projection
inequality because i don't know of an
analog of shadow system
great okay so at the very last
subsection of the paper if you look
uh we give a new proof of petty which is
like
you know two-line proof of petty but not
this
so of course it we discovered it during
our investigation
but so so maybe i will answer i know i'm
out of time but
our proof in some sense is taking
blaschke santalo and extending it to all
case
we don't know how to prove our result by
taking
petty and ext we were expecting to start
from petty
from the case k equals n minus one and
extending it
don't know how to do that there is sir
during our investigation and
hopefully this is described well in the
paper there is some type of duality
between petty and blasphemy between k
and musk there is some type of duality
we don't know how to give
a proof of our result from the petty
side but during our investigation we
found a new very simple proof of petty
using shadow systems which is like two
lines long
yeah i see okay that's okay answered my
question thank you
okay thank you manuel again for this
talk uh i think that we'll postpone the
next lecture by five minutes so
resume at in california time i think
it's 1005. okay so max for what is
actually beginning at 1005
within five minutes basically